[Música]
La cocaína es una economía que tiene
desarrollado en particular un poco en Occidente
guyaneses y a las familias que viven de
este tipo de tráfico por lo que encontramos
varios miembros de la misma familia
quién quién hace este tipo de tráfico este tipo
de transporte hablamos de la mula yo
diría un pequeño estandarte y que lleva
así que ya sea en el equipaje, pero quién puede
también llevan dentro del cuerpo
cocaina en huevo
[Música]
siempre tienes que cuestionarte a ti mismo
porque hay que admitir que hay
siempre un poco tarde hay
un medio de frío que se prueba en él
detecta lo vemos multiplicar que este
ya sea en el vector postal o aquí
viajero lo vemos por lo tanto se usa un
replica de este medio para unos pocos
tiempo y tan pronto como empecemos a ser
efectivo por medio en la detección de
esto significa que hay uno nuevo
nuevos medios que se utilizan
[Música]
[Aplausos]